[Applause]
oh my gosh
first i have to ask why quit your job
on social media with an audience i love
that you did it
what was that all about well i always
like to let people know that it wasn't
like i just quit with no plan
suddenly i'd been planning for a really
long time
and documenting and sharing my
entrepreneurial journey
so it just felt authentic to also share
this part
it's the scariest part for a lot of
people and i wanted to be true to form
so i did it and was there a plan
or a hope that it would inspire others
or is this just what you needed to do
for yourself
maybe a little a column a and a little a
column b right you know
some of it was definitely that i'm the
type of girl where
i needed to scorch that bridge down so
that i wouldn't end up
running back across it when i was scared
but then the other side is i wanted to
really paint a picture of what it looks
like to step into entrepreneurship
that i really wanted people to see the
journey from the beginning and see that
yeah
it's scary but you can still show up
every single day you
say that you can have it all but not at
the same
time yes so it's
more that you can't be all the things to
all the people
all the time right so my big thing is
i spend a lot of my focus on identifying
which
ball i can drop because some balls are
made of glass
and some balls are made of rubber the
glass ones are going to shatter and the
rubber ones are going to bounce back but
no matter what you're going to juggle
them and you're going to drop the ball
so for me it's about knowing which one's
which if i have to miss a carpool pickup
well that's rubber it'll bounce back
i can make it up a different day but if
i have to miss a
milestone recital or a really big
doctor's appointment
well that's glass and i want to make
sure i prioritize those so i can show up
but then let's also grant ourselves some
grace
we're not always going to get it right
you know what's so ironic nicole i love
that you said that
i can give everybody else grace by the
way i have it written on my hands
literally i wrote it down on my hand and
i've been writing it because it's
something that i really lack for myself
i think that's so powerful and
especially as you know
we're both moms of daughters you know i
always think about
my kids are watching me and if they
don't see me extending myself grace and
saying you know what i'm really tired i
think i'm gonna turn in early or
honestly i did my best with this project
i'm just gonna go ahead and let it sit
and try again tomorrow
how on earth will our daughters learn
how to do it for themselves so
i love the idea of putting grace right
in front of you
where you're not going to forget to
extend it all day long
well i actually happen to know how much
your daughters look up to you
check out this mother's day surprise
happy mother's day we just want to let
you know how much you mean to us
and thank you for helping us grow and
become the people that we are today
thank you for helping me talk about my
feelings better
and i want to thank you because you were
the woman who showed me that
i can be gracious and kind while also
following my dreams and being true to
myself
you are a very silly and weird person
we love you bye oh my gosh
you're gonna make me lose my lashes
i love it i hope they run in that river
right away from you
just being a mom is such it's so
important to me because
as an adoptive mother um you know our
family is really special and
we're meant to be together and hearing
that just really
it's just nice to know that they know
how much i love them
were you jeez drew will you speak to me
a little bit about that nicole
about your um family dynamic
we actually met our daughters when their
mother was panhandling
on the side of the street in baltimore
um we pulled over to just kind of
see what was going on and we found out
that
it was a tough situation so we offered
to
me and my husband just will mentor we'll
bring groceries we'll kind of stand
in the gap where we can and uh within 30
days we found out that their mother was
going to be incarcerated
so uh we wanted to make sure the girls
stayed together and so we took them in
and a year later uh we all kind of
decided
with their mother their bio mom included
that it was best if they stuck around
with us
and here we are six years later and i'm
a mom to
three girls ages 9 18 and 22.
nicole when i
was lucky enough to get this job and
it's something i don't take for granted
any day because i just didn't want to be
the kind of mom that wasn't with my kids
you know i needed to have a job that
made me feel like
my kids come first and i just really
have the greatest admiration for you
i love your story i love what a good
person you are
being this brave woman like a fearless
leader who takes on so much and yet
you're a great role model as a mother
and to
all of us other mothers and just women
in general
oh drew you're amazing thank you so much
um it's
a joy to be able to share you know she's
the boss on usa network so that people
can see
that families are made in a lot of
different ways and we're imperfect and
we're doing the best we can
and it's all good enough
yeah it really is nicole and so are you
thank you nicole walters she's the boss
episodes are available on usanetwork.com
and the usa network app